so when Thanos shows up we really wanted
to make this the most powerful moment
ever eyes up
stay sharp the movie sort of keeps
twisting at the end there in ways that
you can't believe that it's going one
step beyond and that the the fate of our
characters and the fate of the universe
are still at play hey everybody it's
Charlie this is gonna be my breakdown of
the alternate infinity war final battle
in a couple of the key battles through
the movie there's even some cool of
venom Easter eggs and all this about
aspects of Infinity Ward that they had
to change early on because of what was
going on with Sony in the venom movie
and how they were trying to keep those
universes separate you may have seen the
videos that I've done earlier this week
about the alternate moments like the
different costumes that people had
there's a bunch of really cool stuff
that we learned about the movie I'm
doing a giveaway for that book all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Marvel related comments on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this I just broke this down top
10 style so starting with number 10
starting at the beginning of the movie
Thanos deploys the outriders at the
beginning during what seems like more of
a full-blown Second Battle of New York
at the sanctum much bigger conflict than
what we saw during the actual movie you
see spider-man trying to save Doctor
Strange just like Iron Man asked him to
do you see him in the background here
getting taken away he's still wearing
the original stark tech suit but he's
getting dog piled by the outriders so it
was a much bigger moment that what
actually ended up in the movie the
version that we saw just willed it down
to ebony maw and Cole obsidian two
really obvious reasons why I think they
changed this big Center in the movie
mainly one to make the Battle of Wakanda
feel like a much bigger reveal like oh
crap when all the outriders come pouring
out that's the first time you're
supposed to have seen them two second
big reason is as they wanted to keep the
budget under control even though Disney
has famously deep pockets it seems like
they have unlimited money they did
actually have a budget for infinity war
in Avengers 4 it was about an average
250 million dollars for each of the
films so half a billion dollars to close
down the first 10 years of Marvel movies
there's on a practical level all these
extra CG characters the outriders in the
beginning of the movie would have added
several million dollars in
post-production nine spider-man Iron Man
and Doctor Strange still white
going into outer space on the Black
Order ship they still had to tighten
eight also at the beginning of the movie
when Thanos comes to Thor's as
guardianship for the tesseract Loki
still gives up the space stone but gets
away on an escape pod surviving two
Avengers for so he's still alive in
present-day in that original version the
Hulk still gets his ass beat by Thanos
Heimdall still uses his dying breath to
call down dark energy from the all
fathers to open a Bifrost sending him to
the sanctum for that Silver Surfer
Easter egg scene but the Hulk storyline
plays out very differently from then on
out so 7 Hulk still turns back into
banner at the sanctum and is unable to
Hulk out for most of the movie they
still do a version of that funny what's
wrong with the Hulk scene when they're
facing the black order dude you're
embarrassing me from the Wizards six
Thor always gets picked up by the
Guardians goes to Nevada Lear to get
storm breaker from the dwarves but the
actual scenes on the Dwarven homeworld
and the way the storm breaker scenes
went down were a little different
because they had a bunch of different
ideas about what that would look like
just the weapon itself and they had a
slightly different idea about how the
narrative would tie back to the forging
of the original Infinity Gauntlet in
Thanos's armor because there was all
this prehistory they had to convey like
what happened to Eitri how his hands had
been chopped off by Thanos so maybe I'll
do a separate video about that sometime
soon because that's a whole separate
thing same deal for Iron Man's
bleeding-edge armor they had a bunch of
different versions for how that worked
and what it looked like all very cool
five the battle on Titan still happens
but spider-man had alternating iron
spider costumes at different points in
the process I've already done a separate
video about this because the Titan
battle was kind of intended to be their
miniature homage to Secret Wars from the
comics so you have a bunch of Avengers
abandoned on an alien planet forced to
do battle
so because of Secret Wars Easter eggs
you have Spider Man they knew they
couldn't do venom because of what was
going on with Sony in the venom movie so
instead of doing the symbiote costume
they do a black iron spider costume
there was also a version of this scene
that was a little bit different with him
in a red gold comic book accurate iron
spider costume but there was also
someone trying to tell me recently that
there was a version of this battle where
Spiderman had been
swapped with the Falcon and Falcon was
the one that went into outer space I
have not seen that version of the script
but maybe it was one of the fake scripts
that they circulated there were several
different versions of fake scripts even
vision Paul Bettany said that he had
three different scripts and there were
only three copies in total of the actual
script that it circulated on the movie
set you have hundreds of actors running
around those Pinewood Studios in Atlanta
but only three copies of the real script
and most of those in the possession of
the Russos at all times and I mentioned
the venom movie giving them spider-man
symbiote problems there was also a
reason why they had to change infinity
war things because of the venom movie
Marvel executives were too worried that
some of the early designs for the
outriders look just like the venom
character so they felt like that would
cause too much confusion so that's why
the outriders ended up looking the way
that they do is a little bit different
from what they look like in the comics
I'll let you guys fantasize about the
version of this movie where Thanos
commands an army of symbiotes for the
Avengers and the guardians still lose on
Titan Thanos still gets the time stone
and still has two Wakanda to get the
mine stone spider-man still dies on the
planet doesn't come back but as you'll
see in a second there were a lot of
physical changes to the way those fights
went down like for instance star-lord
was not responsible for botching the
save they didn't almost get it off of
him but the way things ended on Titan
was always going to be the same because
three the mine stone was always going to
be the final stone that he collected
because of that big vision twist saving
the payoff of killing a really huge
comic-book character who also had an
infinity stone embedded in his forehead
so because everybody in existence knew
that Thanos would have to take that from
him at some point and he was probably
number one on the hit list they wanted
to make the movie more about the
Avengers trying to protect him we don't
trade lives very important Captain
America line that I'm sure they'll
circle back around and pay off during
Avengers for the way they nose gets the
mine stone was a little bit different so
that gauntlet run that he goes on
through the Avengers to try and get to
it goes down very differently to Thor
still comes back plants a fat one right
in Thanos his chest with Stormbreaker
almost killing him in every version you
should have always gone for the head but
you can see that in this version of
events it's more like that battle on
titin where they're all dogpiling him at
the same time like you see Captain
America here almost getting the gauntlet
off like 99% of the way almost there
that's literally the spider-man moment
from the final version that we saw in
theaters the scene plays down almost
exactly the same way with one as you can
see very huge change literally huge in
this case because banner turns back into
the Hulk during the dog pile he's been
unable to turn the entire movie than in
one final desperate attempt to keep
Thanos from the Infinity stone Hulk
returns and if he didn't spot him in the
pile here this is Iron Man's armor
meaning that Tony came back to Wakanda
and you have all of the original
Avengers trying to dogpile Thanos there
are a couple main reasons why I think
they changed this especially like the
big Hulk twist because that was a big
complaint that people had like why give
us Hulk in Wakanda during the trailer
but not pay it off during the movie one
I think they wanted to make it feel like
Thanos progression increased in rate in
voracity so as he gets more stones he
gets more powerful they wanted it to
feel more inevitable by the time he got
to the mine stone while they're still on
Titan they wanted to feel like there was
a chance that the Avengers could still
win but once it gets the time stone and
gets to Wakanda
remember how they play that sad music as
he's running the gauntlet because you
know that things are supposed to be over
they wanted that to feel more like the
end like it's over they're all already
dead it's only a matter of time till he
just plants his feet one right in front
of the other and rips it right out of
vision's forehead the very obvious
reason I think that they didn't put the
hook in this moment here is this also
because they wanted this to feel so
final like The Avengers have lost and if
the Hulk came back in this moment you
would have still felt like there was a
chance like the Hulk is almost
unstoppable maybe he can help them save
the day so in the way that spider-man's
black costume is something that they're
saving for spider-man far from home like
he has the stealth costume even though
it's not the symbiote suit or it's not
like the straight-up black costume from
the comics is the next closest thing
they also want to save Hulk coming back
and of course holding off on bringing
all the original Avengers back together
till Avengers 4 let me know in the
comments which of these alternate scenes
though is your favorite hulk coming back
in that final dogpile in Wakanda or
spider-man in the black costume or
fighting the outriders in the Battle of
New York it's a really cool thing that
just happened while I was in the middle
of making this
we got another look at the Avengers new
white costumes during Avengers 4 so I
might do a video for that tomorrow leave
all your video requests in the comments
below
congratulations Isaiah Isaiah you're the
giveaway winner from my last big marble
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here for my new Avengers 4
trailer video and to learn about all the
Marvel phase 4 projects they just
announced and click here for my new
spider-man black suit video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]